looking at the fantastical world of  pirates of the caribbean some very  cringy cgi wound up being used to bring  these strange scenes to life how did  they make the capitan appear as though  he were a weird ghost covered in small  white dots and with natural hair pulled  back the team captured the motions until  the time came to let cgi work its magic  these ghost sharks are horrifying in  part because of how strange they looked  in reality the actors weren't even  filming at sea and these creepy  creatures were entirely created with vfx  then added to the shots these awkward  sea creatures don't quite hit the mark  the cgi done to create davey jones is  remarkable and the final result is  otherworldly after capturing the  performance on set effects were added  creating an entirely digitally created  character  we've definitely never seen anything  like this strange vfx at their finest